rising from relatively undignified
beginnings
this mysterious bounty hunter has become
one of the most iconic characters in the
star wars galaxy but that hasn't made
him immune from a series of
misconceptions here's a look at some
things you may
incorrectly believe about boba fett
although boba fett wears the same type
of armor as the titular protagonist of
the mandalorian
he isn't part of the mandalorian creed
at least not always
donald f glutt's empire strikes back
novelization states that boba was part
of
a group of evil warriors defeated by the
jedi knights during the clone wars
moreover daniel keys morin's novella the
last one standing a tale of boba fett
which was published in kevin j
anderson's 1996 anthology novel
tales of the bounty hunters gave boba a
real name jaster mirel
and claimed that he was exiled from his
home world of mandalore
this story was canon until george lucas
changed boba's origin
for episode 2 attack of the clones to
make him the unaltered clone and son
of bounty hunter jango fett lucas has
never explained the reasoning behind
this change but morin was ultimately not
upset about it
in a 2018 interview the author noted
that lucas had already changed plenty of
his own previous ideas about star wars
so he wasn't surprised when the
legendary creator decided to alter those
of another writer
chewbacca spent years in boba fett's
crosshairs due to his longtime
friendship with han solo but that
doesn't mean that fett hates all wookies
in fact the darth vader comics reveal
boba worked alongside a wookie named
black persanten when the two were both
employed by job of the hutt and boba
even vouched for the wookie when vader
brought up the possibility of failure
before vader assigned chrysanthen to
capture an agent of the emperor
he ended up going toe-to-toe with
obi-wan kenobi in the comic star wars
number 20 because
jabba tasked cursantin with capturing
the man who kept interfering with the
collection of his water attacks
later in the series kursantin would go
on to fight chewbacca and darth vader
number 14
while trying to capture han solo so
while boba definitely has beef with at
least one wookie
he's capable of getting along with
others opening a previously unknown
chapter in their shared past
marvel comics revealed that boba fett
and luke skywalker met long before they
crossed paths and the empire strikes
back after the events of a new hope
darth vader traveled to tatooine and
assigned boba to hunt down a rebel pilot
associated with a man named obi-wan
kenobi and a smuggling vessel called the
millennium falcon
vader also specified to bring this pilot
back in one piece
boba tracked this bounty down to ben
kenobi's home in the jungle and wastes
and temporarily blinded him with a flash
grenade but the mysterious rebel held
his own against boba
and narrowly escaped his clutches after
all that boba must have been happy to
take a shot at luke and empire even
though boba failed to capture his rebel
quarry
he did give vader a name skywalker for
boba that name wasn't familiar
but for vader it made him rethink
everything emperor palpatine had told
him about the fates of his children
this information may explain why vader
appeared to remain
so calm when the emperor first mentioned
the name skywalker
in empire strikes back boba fett was a
killer even before mace windu
decapitated his father
in attack of the clones in fact when
bova was growing up
django taunt his boy the same skills he
learned as a bounty hunter
including survival and martial arts in
the 2019 comic age of republic
jango fett number one django takes boba
on a mission with three other bounty
hunters as part of his training
the mission is to capture a twilight
girl and return her to her father
but after they find this bounty the
other hunters threaten to kill boba if
he doesn't hand over the twilight girl
of course these two bounty hunters
underestimate the boy
and boba kills them both without his
father's help the comic ends with boba
asking his father if he did all right to
which django responds
you shot well you trusted your judgment
and you've started building your
reputation
a father couldn't ask for a better start
for his son's legacy we don't get a ton
of insight into django's parenting but
at least he cared about his son enough
to prepare him for a galaxy that might
not welcome him with open arms
the current star wars canon portrays
young boba as someone in pursuit of his
father's killer
after the events of attack of the clones
one story arc from the popular animated
series
star wars the clone wars sees boba team
up with bounty hunters ara singh
bosk and costas and impersonate a clone
cadet in order to infiltrate a republic
vessel called the endurance
and kill mace windu in order to gain
vengeance for windu's murder of jango
fett
when the crew ends up taking hostages
however boba begins to become conflicted
about the job
even if it means avenging his father one
of the ark's strengths is that it shows
a post attack of the clones boba as
sympathetic and not just a ruthless
killing machine
this arc sets up the code of honor that
bobo would continue to establish and
refine as he grew into adulthood
boba fett's first movie appearance came
in the empire strikes back but it wasn't
his screen debut
what if he doesn't survive he's worth a
lot to me
boba's first appearance in the star wars
universe actually came during an
animated segment from the infamous 1978
star wars holiday
special which was aired in part to
further stoke anticipation for the
empire strikes back the short seas luke
c-3po and r2d2 crash land on the water
moon of pana
to save han solo and chewbacca who have
also crash-landed
luke 3po and r2 run into boba fett who
saves them from a giant monster with a
weapon similar to the sniper rifle we
now see in the mandalorian
and they decide to team up unfortunately
r2 later finds out that boba is darth
vader's right hand man
despite all its numerous flaws the
holiday special will always have the
honor of giving us boba fett's first
media appearance
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite star wars characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one